je voudrais que les policiers sont pas
différents de la population au tout le
monde a réagi fortement ce qui s'est
passé avec monsieur floride
mais pour nous vous savez ce qui s'est
passé là bord est un événement
extrêmement triste mais l'ensemble de ce
qui doit être fait au québec pour nous
on est complètement ailleurs de ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis
et évidemment c'est pour ça que le juge
après un peu sur le sujet qui est un peu
d'actualité sur différents ding lei de
la police on l'a vu aux états unis.vers
sur ce nouveau au québec
vous savez ici au québec on a déjà en
difficulté sur le financement des villes
comme montréal des vieux comme longueuil
mais québec l'ensemble des municipalités
qui ont de la police municipale ne sont
pas financés du tout actuellement par le
gouvernement du québec alors que
l'ensemble des villes qui sont financés
qui ont la sûreté du québec leur
territoire sont financés à 50 %
aujourd'hui
alors alors sa cause totalement une
iniquité dans le service qui est capable
de tout faire par les services de police
municipaux au québec
et si on remet ça mais évidemment ça ne
va pas il peut faire des projets ça nous
empêche de mettre des choses prenons
juste exemple la camair-co port est l
une des raisons pourquoi sa peau était
mise en place était le coup oui alors si
on revient toujours à ça vous savez le
financement et indistinct hyper
important et juste pour la ville de
montréal ça représente 6,6 et est
financé à la même hauteur que toutes les
autres villes desservies une ville comme
un comme drummondville a reçu plus de 75
millions de financement du gouvernement
d'un dernières années alors que montréal
absolument e-reçu on parle de 360
millions par année le financement qui
qui devrait envoyer par québec à
montréal
et là je parle juste de moyens pour
l'ensemble du québec on parle que de 800
millions est censé les contribuables
savait qu'ils sont les payeurs de taxes
municipales qui doivent absolument pays
est ce que ça fait c'est que ça donne un
service ciblé de police à deux vitesses
au québec alors dans le redire c'est
qu'ils manquent de financement dans les
grandes villes comme montréal
comme longuet parce qu'ils ont pas ils
ont pas le financement de québec le pour
avoir les services as qu exactement
alors nous on est vous savez une grande
différence entre les états unis et le
québec est le plus militarisé qu'ici 2 1
et 2 2 les montagnes sont à louer les
services de police il est beaucoup plus
grand ici au québec on se retrouve pas
du tout à la même endroit sur les
questions du biscione qui se posent aux
états unis.vers sur le québec
bien au contraire et si on se retrouve
dans une situation où ce que québec dans
le contexte où ce que depuis vingt ans
ne commun un service de police à deux
vitesses alors nous on se retrouve
vraiment dans une situation ce que pour
mercer égal pour donner des services
les mêmes services partout au québec il
faudra avoir le même financement qui
sera donné il savait sur son conjoint
ont rejoint notre voie aux municipalités
qui a actuellement sur 100 % des coûts
alors que québec paye 100 pour 50% des
coûts pour les villes qui sont
desservies par la sûreté du québec alors
c'est totalement inéquitable pour les
citoyens du québec pour majorité parce
que n'oubliez pas que la police
municipale
on est dans près de deux tiers des
municipalités du québec de la population
du québec
donc on est dans beaucoup de villes
ayant beaucoup de villes qui reçoivent
absolument rien pour la police
municipale ma question c'était comment
réagissent vos membres face à ces
demandes de conques on attend un peu
partout de de réformer le financement
est ce qu'on est pauvre est ce qu'on est
ouvert où c'est un non catégorique en
raison le des raisons financières vous
ne donniez tantôt écouter non non
membres truth extrêmement dur
actuellement ce qui se passe parce que
vous savez mes yeux c'était une erreur
grave qui s'est passé c'était un geste
grave qu'on a assisté d'un an dans la
mort de monsieur flo et et non j'ai trop
extrêmes en tissu et demi j'ai comparé
est ce qui s'est passé là bord alors
actuellement c'est déjà difficile
maintenant sur le financement
quand je vous dis on est tellement
ailleurs sur le dossier du financement
parce que le contexte du québec fraq
actuellement on n'est plus à la
recherche de financements que dans un
mode de tir
il va falloir baisser le financement qui
est bien qu'on n'est pas du tout du tout
du tout donc nos gens s'y retrouvent
pour un quart sur 7 sur 7 sur cette
analyse là dans l'es9 ici c'est donc
c'est pas le temps de couper parce qu'il
y en a pas assez dans le fond c'est ça
qu'on doit retenir ce que bien au
contraire on se retrouve avec des grands
défis au québec on se retrouve on a
parlé de santé mentale
on a parlé aussi de se rapprocher les
communautés alors pour donner un service
qui soit en fonctions - et le dis
souvent c'est les services de proximité
c'est les services qui seront calquées
sur les besoins locaux qui vont faire
qu'on va donner un meilleur service à la
population
et dans ce contexte de la main nos gens
nos élus doivent pas des choix
difficiles des fois on peut construire
entre faire une route où la police est
actuellement il ya ils reçoivent
absolument aucun financement dans les
autres villes au québec en reçoivent
alors nos pôles chinon policière au
québec le regarder ça et se disent on
n'est pas du tout à cet endroit alors
nous concevons certains évidemment on
parle d'une réforme
je pense que le mot est beaucoup trop
grands mangent pas d'améliorer les
services on va toujours être ouvert et
améliorer les services et ça ça fait
partie
c'est un peu dans cette approche qu'on
sent qu'on combat self qu'on va aller
si vous voulez dans le livre vert
l'objectif c'est d'améliorer les
services et de toujours faire mieux
il ya pour personne lalonde qui ne
peuvent rien alors on est ouvert mais
certains étant ça fait 20 ans que la loi
de police avait prôné serment été
revisitée et dans ce contexte là bien on
va s'investir dans le livre vert mais je
savais s'il ya pas d'argent il n'y a pas
de possibilité d'améliorer les services
s'est dit ça devient difficile sur 51
devrait offrir ces services là ce
n'était pas nécessairement la peau les
offres et ses fêtes ses services le
canadien je vais vous dire une chose on
a eu plusieurs beaux projets partout au
québec où ce que des intervenants
sociaux qui vivaient sur des
interventions avec des policiers mais il
reste que pour paver deux policiers
parce que lorsque la personne est en
crise lorsque la personne ou sur une
obligation d'intervention physique c'est
pour les intervenants sociaux qui peut
la faire ça en l'air pour le travail du
pôle chimie qui doit être des deux
points qui doivent être
faite sur cet appel la seule chose c'est
que dans notre l'offre de service qu'on
fait on a on rajoute un individu qui
vient et aider à notre intervention
mais on peut pas enlever des policiers
on n'est pas là surtout quand au québec
le nombre de policiers par habitant
n'est pas un des plus beaux au monde
non non on n'est pas du tout à cet
endroit alors lorsqu'on regarde la
situation du québec versus le reste du
monde je comprends pas son nom mais je
rappelle vous êtes président de la
fédération des policiers et policières
municipaux du québec merci d'avoir pété
nous parler aujourd'hui
mais se moque ou bien apprécié